well there are lots of indications that
there still racism in American society
if we look at overall indicators for
life chances life expectancy income
wealth educational attainment and
performance within schools we still see
discernible differences in performance
between whites and Asians and blacks and
Latinos in the United States some of
those differences are attributed to
systemic or structural factors and to
the extent that we can explain those
differences by systemic and structural
factors and we can that is evidence of
racism in American society in addition
while we don't see a lot of the racial
violence that we saw a century ago we
still see examples of overt racial
violence in the United States today for
instance the Southern Poverty Law Center
has just released a report that
indicates that there is a lot of racial
violence in the south directed towards
Latinos under the guise of xenophobia
and anti-immigration stances and so when
we see these things happening when we
see news incidences on the rise in 2007
towards African Americans we can still
say that there are still bigotry racism
and Prejudice in American society
well indicates tremendous progress it
demonstrates the power and influence of
the African American vote and it's
remarkable that African Americans have
been able to exercise their political
influence such a way 40 years after the
passage of the Voting Rights Act now 44
years after the passage of the Voting
Rights Act it is a testament to the
increasing tolerance of non black
communities and putting their faith and
confidence in someone like Barack Obama
to be their President of the United
States if we look at other candidacies
for the presidency for instance Jesse
Jackson's Democratic candidacies in 1984
1988 people were not prepared to elect
an african-american president at that
time so the fact that Obama was able to
make it past the nomination stage and to
win the presidency shows tremendous
racial progress in this country
a post-racial society should we ever get
there would be a society where when
social scientists like me run our models
and we include a race as a dummy
variable race is no longer statistically
significant and we're just not there yet
so anytime we run a model we see
significant differences in some of the
indicators that I mentioned before
education and calm life expectancy
probability of going to jail other types
of things and once those things are no
longer being predicted by race then we
can say that we're in a post-racial
Society but its health and people's race
still is actually very significant in
their lives and as an aside for the
president most people argue that his
race wasn't a hindrance to him and in
fact it may have been a help to him
racism and racial stereotyping cut both
ways it can cut in negative ways and it
can cut in positive ways and so in many
ways President Obama represented the
exception that proved the rule that
still reifies the notion of race in our
society and it still reifies negative
stereotypes towards African Americans
and while it makes us feel good and it
may make us feel progressive or liberal
or cosmopolitan there's still some
underlying racial prejudice that goes
into the attitude and we need to be very
mindful of that
I think as post-racialism is being
constructed in popular media today I
think it does actually have the
potential to water down diversity and
helps to obscure the need to appreciate
people's diversity often times people
will be indeed the term post-racialism
during the last election as a shortcut
to be able to not deal with persistent
racism in American society actually
wrote about this in the Washington Post
and got attacked for it um so people
could say I voted for Barack Obama
therefore I am NOT prejudiced I voted
for Barack Obama therefore there's no
racism in American society anymore you
know one historic election while
important and while pivotal is not
necessarily a sign that we have
completely turned the corner and we
always have to be vigilant about our own
prejudices our own attitudes and this
goes for minorities and non-minorities
alike to be able to be on our guard to
recognize that we're all capable of
slipping back into old patterns of
action if we declare 2009 the
post-racial age in America we end up
sort of failing to recognize that we are
all still human and that we are all
still very susceptible to allowed really
bad attitudes towards other groups
black leadership today looking at the
people who have been dubbed post-racial
leaders in American society people like
President Obama people like Governor
Deval Patrick or Mayor Cory Booker
Adrian Fenty or congressman Archer Davis
or Harold Ford Oh a debt of gratitude to
the african-american forebears who came
before them who were not always welcome
in mainstream political circles who were
perceived as being racialized who are
often defined in direct opposition to
this young cadre of leadership and and
most of them do recognize that they owe
a debt of gratitude to the trailblazing
steps that those forefathers and
foremothers made for them in terms of
the current electoral system in which
many young black politicians are running
they do really seek out alliances with
Latinos in their communities and so we
know in this past election that one of
the things that helped Barack Obama and
his quest for the presidency was
increased democratic voting amongst
Latinos and so for the previous two
election cycles we had seen Latinos
identifying increasingly with the
Republican Party in terms of their vote
we saw that tide switch there's actually
going back to more normal historic
levels of voting behavior amongst
Latinos there are a lot of cities where
there are blacks and Latinos who live
side-by-side and where both groups make
up a significant portion of the
population and you do need Latino
support in order to create a multiracial
coalition that puts blacks in office so
to that extent yes there are some cities
where you don't see blacks and Latinos
living in the same space or in the same
political jurisdiction and so those
alliances are less salient and in those
races but you know in most races you do
need a broad multiracial coalition and
that certainly includes Latinos
I study african-american leadership and
particularly interested in questions of
generational transition amongst African
Americans so I'm interested in black
politicians born after 1960 what are the
implications for having been born after
the civil rights movement having been a
beneficiary of the civil rights movement
in terms of being able to run for
political office and being able to
change the landscape of what we usually
consider an African American political
agenda so this has led to me editing one
book coming out later this year called
whose black politics cases in
post-racial black leadership and I just
received a contract for my book that
focuses on Newark New Jersey called
Newark in the clash of two black
Americas with respect or relating to
these issues I am interested in the
intersection of race and class in
particular and looking at class-based
politics so usually we think about
African American politics in terms of
its deep political unity so we look at
the fact that 90% of African Americans
usually both democratic and presidential
elections that was 95 percent in 2008
and we look at partisan identification
in the african-american community being
about 80 percent democratic and so
people assume that blacks are a
monolithic political group we've always
known that that wasn't true but they're
generally forces such as discrimination
and racism that have compelled
african-americans to close ranks
politically so my questions tend to ask
well what happens within this Democratic
coalition when you have
african-americans who represent
different political agendas who
represent different political eras and
who very explicitly represent different
types of class politics what's the
impact on what we think of as that
classic african-american political
agenda we're talking about reducing
inequality addressing poverty how to
address poverty and what ways to frame
that and so there's definitely a
generational battle within African
American communities over these issues
and there's been this long-standing
discussion about the efficacy of
adopting what we would call de
racialized politics and political
science but what I think most
journalists are calling post-racial
politics so the politics of racial
transcendence not necessarily making
explicit racial appeals to African
American
Unity's there are lots of people who are
very concerned that when candidates do
not talk about race on the campaign
trail that they are hamstrung from being
able to address race on a very forceful
and explicit way once they're in office
now that we have a critical mass of
quote/unquote post-racial young black
political leaders who have used these d
racial s strategies to get into office
we now are going to be in a position to
be able to test whether or not they are
effective in their office whether they
are more effective than their black
predecessors and whether or not we can
actually advance that classic
african-american political agenda going
forward